how did you feel when you saw the op-ed  for the first time it was like somebody  hit me in the back of the head with a  two by four if I had done an interview  to try to explain myself it turned into  a hit piece when did you first learn  that Disney was not going to recast you  in the Pirates franchise probably two or  three days after this op-ed appeared  Captain Jack Sparrow was a character  that I had built from the ground up  having added much of myself much of my  own rewriting of the dialogue and scenes  and the jokes I didn't quite understand  how after that long relationship and  quite a successful relationship  certainly for Disney but suddenly I was  guilty until proven innocent